[Musique]
l'image que vous retenez sur ces 1000
émission milliers mais pour en choisir
une qui est un peu symbolique moi j'ai
choisi
nabila a wish fais dit nabila parce qu
on voulait kamerhe soit pouvait pas nos
bilans l'ombre à merde à part on
embrasse nabila et voulons voir parce
qu'apparemment ils pouvaient pas venir
elle était ton stage chez kill doug
année c'est ça va
c'est vrai que les périodes mais les
ailes et où aller ou déjà en tant
qu'homme mais hélas non elle allonge
nabila et voilà elle nous a fait hurler
de rire parce qu'elle a fait des ennemis
quant à la des moules à cake ouais j'ai
vu aussi qu'elle est le client mais
c'est qu'on a là des moulins kewell et
la cgt a dénombré inquiet qu'on pensait
qu'elle allait le mettre simplement dans
l'assiette tout ce qui est à vous allez
voir regarder 2 3 la ville a franchement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai grillé un
comprimé nabila j'ai un truc à vous dire
vous avez le bonjour papier
question est-ce que nabila vous mentent
sur twitter oui ou non et si cas quel
manque nabi d'armé actuellement qu à moi
j'ai pris ça vous manque
willy bernard oui oui oui sa balle au
filet oui mais catherine d'abord vous
étiez vous manque ah oui oui j'ai
conseillé dans une émission et je les
trouvais je la trouve très belle très
intuitive elle a beaucoup de qualités
non mais c'est vrai j'aime beaucoup
aussi à nous parce que lui il aime pas
les bons choix d'abidal jean michel
lemaire non parce que je trouvais elle
était là j'ai bien aimé quand était là
mais elles ne montrent pas voilà il a
donné tout ce qu'elle a mal de mes choux
d'accord on va très bien et makyol vous
manque non du tout enora non mais pas
pour les raisons vous pensé pour les
raisons que jean michel viens d'évoquer
elle a fait son temps elle a été super
dans tpm paix quand elle était là là là
puis sa place à plein de deux nouveaux
jeunes regardent et agathe regarder
ludivine qui étaient là qui est
formidable qui arrivait ya deux jours
mais sur l'art c'est un autre délire
c'est un opc un milliard de lires
matthieu delormeau royal et le moment
que vous retenez vous de tpm paix sûre
c'est une idée que je retiens mais aussi
parce que je voulais faire plaisir aux
chroniqueurs qui me le demandent
beaucoup également aux fans
à l'odeur mres donc modestement une
image de moi tu aurais pu prendre
quelqu'un doute à vous écouter c'est ce
qui m'est venu vous vous revenez d'un
marathon j'ai fait avec un petit hommage
à sya à camille avec qui on faisait
beaucoup de lait sera avec nous dans
tout le prime une de leurs modèles
c'était la première et sa veste et
rigoles ou quoi c'est ce que vous
retenez tout et pdg parti une chose d
autre mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
6 7 8 9 10 attention et
tout d
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quai conti gabarit
[Applaudissements]
la leur
dans la fosse 2 à 4 personnes qui sont
vraiment des détracteurs de tpm à des
tests l'émission mais vont se régaler
les oreilles j'espère les arguments pour
les faire changer d'avis pas parce qu'on
a eu tout bon soin plateau et on voulait
faire pour cette 8e s'il ya quoi que les
gens qui aiment les messieurs vous avez
retenu quoi vous moi j'ai choisi un
extrait mythique des cafetières de jean
luc lemoine qu'on embrasse d'ailleurs
parce qu'il n'est pas là ce soir mais on
avait vu et c'est un dialogue de sourds
entre jean michel maire et thierry
moreau si je vous dis pas ce mois
l'autre combat ça c'est horrible
alcoolisées mais je crois qu'on s'est
laissé aller franchement y'a des trucs
cochons
cyril vous appelez quiconque
l'astronaute connaissances appliquées
pour passe mal autres contes
commissariat derrière le conte ici pour
parler
[Applaudissements]
deux heures
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est petit extrait ce que dans oui mais
bon c'était pas la meilleure
intervention suis ravi d'être là non
c'était un petit extrait ce que la
séquence était beaucoup plus longue
demain que vous étiez très bonne partie
à new york ont sonné il avait connu des
pompiers ensemble tous à être
apparemment il ya le feu dans leur
relation géraldine maillet est ce que
vous aimez les marivaudages dé quoi il
m'arrive bien sûr les jeux de l'amour et
du hasard assure bon et le jeu de
l'amour et du hasard et du hasard c'est
margot d'âge au marivaudage alors que
vous aviez compris à décrocher on va
vous comprenez vous ce coin là j'essaye
c'est l'évidente remi babalola
il manquerait plus le contraire et moi
j'aime votre relation et gêner votre
relation fusionnelle et passionnelle
avec camille combal
non c'est pas avec moi toujours dit non
c'est non parce que celle là elle est un
peu factice alors que l'autre était
vraiment sincère et la laissant jouer
une sorte de voile à la tête des changes
fort et vous avez vous alors poste de
surveillance voilà me combal et ça
dégénère en bataille de mousse à raser
je me rappelle pas du tramway en 2014
pas du tout non mais je vais regarder
mais chez vous je vais faire le clip de
cette chanson puisque vous n'avez plus
me voir vous allez faire attention mais
n'était pas là
m
je parle et où voilà
n'était pas là je m'étais vous
battu par arrêtez vous
[Musique]
juste seul en fait alors je vous aime la
taille de mousse à raser sol qiam a
évoqué mais qui sait sacré marivaudage
on a eu du marais de deuil du
marivaudage nice a envie de savoir ce
qu'il a choisi moi est ce que j'ai
choisi gérard choisi de mettre à la
table piégée oui ça c'est énorme ça
j'adore je vais vomir parce que les
messieurs sont quand même gentil mais
fort mais et c'était pénible
allez c'est parti c'est parti c'est
parti un piéton âgé surprise pour vous
on a eu beaucoup
m
[Applaudissements]
air france est mise au fond du verre la
nouvelle mais bernard je vous dirais que
c'est un très bon moment à vouloir
sortir seul on va la refaire cette table
vous inquiétez pas à gaz n'ont souvent
la dame moi j'ai choisi une séquence
avec le meilleur d'entre nous donc
mathieu dollars oui c'est qu'en ce qui
le met bombardé souvent l'émission vous
avez choisi quoi gilles verdez comme
extraits alors moi ce que j'aime c'est
quand vous faites des farces et
notamment je suis et notamment convoqué
les chroniqueurs dans votre bureau
c'est fort très important décisif pour
notre carrière
et parfois comme cet exemple grâce à se
passe pas comme prévu
notamment on va les réunir et l'autre on
dirait qu'ils ont xtreemos faire en
direction du prime time et d'anciennes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
m
me rappelle très bien ça sature je vais
vous leur faire ça ici je vous le
refaire à bientôt et farces et maxime et
senna maxime gainey oui c'est là bas ça
lui maxime kenny oui vous avez un micro
encore vitro pour l'instant parce qu'il
a il a choisi un extrait aussi il ya
christophe carrière au sénat et là c'est
investir un peu cocasse à l'auteur et
chroniqueur avec l'un des plus polluants
des chroniqueurs c'est camille combal
il a fait un chute sud sud avec l'équipe
2 de broadway nom de baby sitting et il
s'est baigné dans un mojito géant
c'est juste que tu es là royal y est
cocasse on dirait un gars du public me
dans une manif façon celui qui a la tête
de mort devra faire le mojito xxl 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
les balais
on mélange est là alors c'est pas si mal
je suis un epr en groupe si tu disais
pas dégueu
dans un un score et qui passera tout le
prime avec nous un joli camille combal y
en aura aussi des détracteurs de touche
pas à mon poste qui vont arriver vous
catherine laborde alors votre extrait
c'est ce que vous avez choisi sa méthode
ne votent pas ben non parce que vous
avez choisi j'ai choisi comme vous quand
vous avez voulu entrer à tf1 haha
parce que c'était juste avant danse avec
les stars étaient en fait on est allé
plein de fois un f1 quand même eu
ennemis mais vous êtes payé jusqu'à 23
heures
on va regarder ce qu'on fait ces
bouffons de tf1 non
oh
très pénible mais c'est alors voilà
alors donc ils ont été des progrès pour
la police font leur métier tf1 qui les a
envoyés ils ont appelé le préfet de
police non voilà ils sont aller très
très loin pour dire il fallait pas de
show viennent mais les chéris
[Rires]
attendez les séries ne nous emballons
pas trop vite
on va regarder l'extrait qu'a choisi
catherine laborde c'est notre dernière
visite à tf1 oui on va voir le sondage
sur twitter cité les téléspectateurs qui
cite qu'on ne va pas tes photos on ira
pas été un moyen d'attirer ici je
mangerai des petits canapés en loge
gentiment et je fermerai ma tronche ena
mais je vous le dis hein on à regarder
l'extrait et je vous donnerai le sondage
août après voilà donc calé deux motos
qui sont là la police et la pauvreté ce
travail mais tf1 ils ont appelé la
police
voilà ils ont des problèmes de voisinage
apparemment je lacombe est ce que vous
pouvez faire quelque chose contre ces
problèmes de votre fils de la fftri qui
sonnait les policiers sont non mais là
ces deux motos à vendre merci
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire un truc à tf1 franchement
les chéris alors d'accord je comprends
que vous ne voulez pas que je vienne en
plus moi c'était juste pour vous
remercier parce que je vous dis les
anciens patrons tf1 sont étaient nos
anciens patrons donc je voulais juste
aller le remercier leur dire merci parce
que si on aime vous vouliez faire la
bizarre après qu'un oui exactement oui
je voulais faire la bise ara aprikian et
xavier bron deux oui je pense que la
police a d'autres choses à faire que de
surveiller ses 10 ans sur le bus c'est
écrit en route vers tf1 on l'a vu depuis
2009 l'opération des yeux partout avant
de regarder choisi catherine là bas
combien donner une ambiance si les noms
ni blanche ni au niveau
voilà voilà ce qu'on peut faire juste un
truc avant de partir est-ce qu'on peut
pas faire juste une petite chenille dans
le hall de tf1 j'ai fait deux ans et
termine à la fin
c'est la jeune équipe
mme ashton
je
[Musique]
cette année
voici
sa démarche est salutaire c'est par ici
on va voir le sondage dans le trash quoi
[Applaudissements]
on va attendre un peu c'est serré s'est
collé serré où le téké cadence et si je
fais partie pour nous tes calais sans
manette pour qu'on va attendre
on prendra la décision d'alentour de 21h
les loups aux instances et johnny malouf
pas un instant il y aura quatre
détracteurs de tpm pellet shihri mais
juste avant on continue avec les
extraits que vous avez choisi de touche
pas à mon poste et j'espère bien sûr
qu'on ira tf1 mais si les
téléspectateurs sont pas d'accord pour
l'instant ses 47 53
voilà je vais vous demander aussi à vous
aussi si vous voulez qu'on y aille parce
que ça a marqué l'histoire
je pense qu'à voler les remercier nos
anciens patrons oui ça ouais j'ai failli
me faire virer la dernière fois commence
pas encore je le maire n'a pas là bas eh
bien cette fois ci on vous loupera pas
agathe vous avez choisi quel extrait qui
vous a marqué te plait pas alors donc
avec matthieu delormeau un extrait qu'il
le met en plus bien en valeur parce que
c'est l'une des seules fois où je les
trouvais à la fois drôle mignon touchant
sincère l'arrêt à kader stories d'un
amour impossible quand il a fait sa
demande en mariage à camille combal ah
bah oui à la rigueur je ne me rappelle
pas du tout mais ça n'est pas mon ami
mon garçon je te le demande
solennellement
[Applaudissements]
je peux répondre ouais bah tu sais que
j'aime beaucoup
j'ai fait mais tu sais que tu as mais là
c'est beaucoup là ça veut dire oui alors
c'est plus vers le non l'a quand même
con
soit deux jours après que sur twitter
vous pouvez nous poser toutes les
questions que vous voulez un bien sûr
lors de sept millièmes alors regardez je
crois qu'il ya quelqu'un qui souhaite
nous poser une question sur twitter à
les y envoyer
soyez honnête est-ce que vous avez déjà
failli quitter l'émission pour aller
ailleurs tient alors est-ce qu'il y en a
déjà un
alors que mathieu là mais c'est la
vérité
non la vérité non la vérité non j'avais
des propositions qui m'avait beaucoup
touché mais non j'ai pas fait des
propositions qui vous ont touché et
bouteilles cfa ou julien non mentionnés
par les mardis moi non non vous gens me
aba moi la question se pose pas personne
n'a jamais rien proposé doit être les
bonnes questions
non il aura vous avez dû avoir des
propositions et un champignon est réussi
si je pense donc bon bâton mais là elle
a eu des propositions de sa fille oui ça
m'arrive d'avoir des propositions elle a
eu des propositions fin vous ou que
c'est vrai a eu des conditions
d'ailleurs à la garde et la tenue elle
devait être à l'accueil de rtl comme il
est arrivé que vers tel soir a cédé
contente que je fasse toujours par m'en
parler du chara que ce que le soleil
avait dansé avec un ours alors que moi
quand je dors sur les clous ah oui je
suis une verrière cette phrase rendez
compte danse avec un ours brun
franchement je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens dans la vie qu'on dansait avec
un autre homme souvenez parti dit en
fait avec ces sociétés colas question au
départ sur la médium elle arriva roulons
à relation choisi comme extrême ou alors
c'est un extrait avec les invités eric
et ramzy
comme vous avez le sens du petit truc
qui fait plaisir vous avez proposé à
eric un cadeau qu'ils valident rockeur
une séance de massage
alors que vous avez réussi telle
expression peinture à offrir d'être très
drôle à regarder et ça passe un massage
à la turque
il sert pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas mal en fait c'est un gars qui est
pas mal d'invités qui ne veulent plus
venir
vous l'avez compris